is Jay fingers your real name it is not
it is not okay that is it your stage
name it it is it's my my n de plume or
whatever I I'm really I'm really
impressed that you asked that because
most people
don't most
people they just don't um I I did have
someone say that she knew a person with
the last name finger and so just assume
that you know yes this is you know this
is your real name or but it's not it's
um it's a college
nickname and um it was actually given to
me by I'm not going to call them bullies
oh but it's a crew of upper classmen
when I was a freshman crew of upper
classman that I wanted to you know kind
of hang around and you know be seen with
and and they let me kind of hang around
but they also made fun of me and fingers
was the nickname that they came up with
uh it's actually movie based they were
watching Marked for Death I believe it
was Steven Seagal film and there's a
character named fingers and he goes
crazy in one scene and I happen to walk
into the room when that scene was going
on and they're just like ah your fingers
your fingers and it stuck but rather
than be embarrassed by it I embraced it
and it really just got to the point
where everyone started calling me
fingers you know even professors and and
everything like that so I've I've been
Jay fingers for many many years now and
as I say I I've I've embraced it you
know it is it really speaks to who I am
uh my true personality I think I thought
it was for tapping the keys of the uh
keyboard okay so so there's another
story to it do you still keep in contact
with those upper classmen some of them
some of them um but eventually I just
met up with another group of like-minded
people and you know we became a really
strong crew essentially a family and
those people I'm very much you know uh
in contact I'm daily contact with with
those guys so so I left the the upper
classman alone and and and stuck with
the community that really embraced me
for for who I was how was your name a
blessing and a curse it's a blessing
because it's
memorable
um people they don't they don't forget
Jay fingers uh you know I queried a
screenplay uh uh to this manager and you
know he gave me a polite pass but he saw
me on Twitter and you know remembered
the name and you started following me
and engaging with me and that's just one
of those things you know I know that
it's a memorable name when people see my
books they see the name and even if they
don't read the book or whatever they
know oh you Jay fingers he's an author
um
in another lifetime I actually promoted
parties and you know my name would be on
the flyer and people would associate me
with a good party a good time so in that
way yes it's it's definitely a
blessing but curse
wise people look at the name and they
think oh there's something funny there
is there anything salacious going on
with this guy you know it's so
ridiculous so there's that I do have to
to contend with that but honestly for
the most part people people accept it
they they don't come at me in a negative
way about the name right I mean I could
see it to being for a musician as well
you know you're tapping the keys of of
the piano or whatever right right I have
had people you know yeah do you play the
piano or are you a DJ or something like
that so yeah can we talk about what the
little boy was like who grew up wanting
to write an award awardwinning
screenplay sure um he was he very much
an
outcast I'll say
that it still is
nowcast but I grew up in a time where
being a filmmaker being a screenwriter
that wasn't a goal that everyone had
that wasn't a career that everyone
looked at and thought Oh okay you know I
still grew up in the do
lawyer president astronaut era you can
be whatever but you know always you know
having this dream people looked at it
kind of funny they thought that wasn't
realistic didn't even know what it was
um I do remember
someone saying to me you know filmmaker
what is what is that what does that
mean you make films you make movies oh
you want to be a director well why
didn't you say that you know
so it was just it was looked at as being
a strange goal uh a strange
aspiration but my love of movies was
undeniable you know everyone in my
family they they could see it uh and
they did encourage it uh I got my love
of movies from both of my parents from
my mother and my father and so they
would they would do a lot of things to
to kind of help the facilitate the
stream uh there weren't many screenplays
that were available at the time but the
ones that were available my mother found
and and would give to
me uh books on screenwriting I think at
the time Sid field was probably when I
was young was probably the only book
that was out there uh Sidi screenplay
and she got that for me and I devoured
it
um you know just little things like
making sure we had cable so that I could
watch movies on HBO and Cinemax like
these were things that that you know I
know my parents did uh my father always
took me to the
movies
um but yeah uh it
was like I said it was it was it was
looked at as an uncommon dream an
uncommon kind of uh
goal but I do thank my parents and my my
immediate family for supporting that
goal
uh and I guess they realized that I was
serious about it because it's it's I've
never wavered from that you know it's
never been like okay now I want to be a
firefighter or you know now I do want to
be you know president or whatever I've
always had the goal of being a filmmaker
specifically being a screenwriter you
know writing movies and and doing that
why do you say you were an
outcast because again it was it was it
was uncommon you know people didn't know
what I was saying what I was talking
about my interests were far you know
different from everyone else's interest
you know I wasn't the kid that was
outside playing football or climbing
trees maybe every once in a while but
you know like kids have have I think you
know all these interests that can be is
normal it's like okay you know I I
understand he you know yeah he likes
football or or you know she might like
fashion or whatever um but for me to say
I I like movies I love
movies that's what I want to do I want
to
write and I'll also say this
especially like within the black
community
not to say that
um intelligence is looked down
upon that's because that's not what I
want to communicate
but an intelligent you know young black
child you know is just kind of looked at
differently you know it's like the Steve
urle thing you know that was a very real
thing you're just looked at as an other
and if you have interests that don't
align with what people are used to or
you know uh what they think you should
be into then yeah you'll be you'll be
othered you'll just be looked at
strangely and treated treated strangely
as
well and you grew up where I grew up in
Memphis
Tennessee uh the orange Mound orange
Mound neighborhood of Memphis Tennessee
I always have to mention that when
talking about um Memphis um just it's
like the largest black community outside
of Harlem at one point and uh if you
think about like hip-hop music uh the
hip-hop that came out of
Memphis uh primarily like came out of
orange Mound apal MJG they were like the
first big act to uh hip-hop act to come
out of
Memphis so and you left there to go to
Florida State or Miami uh University of
Miami University of Miami sorry okay
yeah and you know that the thinking
behind that I applied to several
different film schools I applied to like
NYU UCLA
USC I applied to some other schools that
didn't really have film programs but I
wanted to follow with the footsteps of
some of my favorite filmmakers you like
Spike Lee Spike Lee went to Morehouse
for undergrad so I applied to
Morehouse but uh I ended up going to the
University of Miami and it was because
my father my father said
that it's tropical you know the weather
is similar to the weather you get out in
California I don't think that's
true but that was part of it and he also
he also thought that going to a school
like Miami and being in their film
program would make me a big fish in a
small pond whereas oh if you go to you
know NYU or if you go to UCLA
everyone you know that's where they go
to go to film school and you won't stand
out as much so that's why I ended up
going to
Miami